Ukraine is not a NATO member and though
the West is supporting Ukrainian forces
we're not engaged in direct combat with
Russia if there has been a deliberate
attack on NATO soil though that could
change and Canada a NATO member would be
part of it our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is with me Mercedes
it is a tense time what are the next
steps in terms of NATO's response
it is Donna and what's expected next
from all of the sources I've spoken to
is that there may be Article 4 invoked
that's basically a meeting and it's a
meeting that happens whenever member
states feel that their territorial
Integrity or security might be
threatened it's very different than
article 5. Article 5 is an attack on one
is an attack on all and that's only been
invoked once in NATO history and that
was by the United States after 9 11. but
even Article 5 is not an automatic Call
to Arms for those who are feeling
anxious about what's happening tonight
there's a lot of discussion that would
have to happen and a lot of belief that
this would have to have been deliberate
and worth a military response before
that would happen one of the senior
folks in the military who I was spoken
speaking to earlier tonight said to me
look if we put this into Russia's hands
and allowed them to decide what the
trigger was was something as simple as a
single strike we would be out of control
the reality is at the end of the day
this will largely be decided by the
United States of America and of course
it will depend on whether or not this
was a deliberate or an accidental strike
and that's something that really is
still being determined at this point so
likely at this point Donna that it would
be article four not Article 5 which is
basically a meeting that's been invoked
seven times before in fact it was also
invoked when Russia initially invaded
Ukraine by seven NATO members who were
concerned about their territorial
Integrity including Poland this would
not be the first time that Russia has
potentially accidentally struck a
country that is not Ukraine they hit
Moldova back in October but there was
less discussion on that because Moldova
is not a NATO country the military
sources I spoke to also told me the
Russians have largely run out of
precision Munitions they are using
dumber and dumber bombs and they don't
have great discipline or leadership
which could account for a strike so of
course we're waiting to find out what
happened but all those things come into
consideration what is Canada's response
at this stage
well Donna at this point it's pretty
muted we heard from Melanie Jolie who is
the Minister of Foreign Affairs she's at
the G20 uh very recently take a listen
to what she had to say
so obviously we're following up this
situation very closely uh we're in
contact with Poland as well as with our
partners
um my heart is with the family and loved
ones of the victims and also with the
people of Poland just kind of believe
this triggers article 5.
we're following up this situation very
closely and of course we'll be having
important meetings today with allies
so as you can see there Donna very very
careful there's a lot of phone calls I'm
told by senior officials going on behind
the scenes to the United States Poland
NATO and even they're trying to find out
from Russia what may have happened here
but right now everyone is being very
careful with their words a reminder
there are 40 Canadian combat engineers
currently in Poland but there's of
course no suggestion that they were
involved anywhere near the strike but
for those wondering about Canadian
Forces there that's who's in the region
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thanks